everyone is always going to find
something in your success or in your
story or upbringing that will try to
knock you down
I want a friend of mine says something
negative and I was like don't put that
in the universe thank you put that out
there when I get to the court so you
know I have my bag and I'm wearing my my
hat in my in my hoodie this is my office
like that's my workplace and I am like
I'm laser-focus need motivation watch a
top 10 of belief nation what's up at
7:00 my one word is believe and I
believe in you I believe you have an
amazing gift inside you that I want to
see explode out onto the world so let's
get your motivation to attend and get
you believing in you grab a snack and
chew in today's lessons from a woman
whose parents had to flee Russia because
they were concerned about the side
effects and fallout of the Chernobyl
nuclear accident to becoming the world's
number one female tennis player five
different times
she's Maria Sharapova and here is my
take on her top ten rules a success
enjoy
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one always aim to win I don't
know how to differentiate an exhibition
to a real match like I just know one way
I think that's the way that I play and
I'm focused and I'm pumping my fist and
I'm excited after a good point and I'm
emotional and you know I I think
exhibitions are also a way to show your
personality and be you know funny and
fun and enjoy the crowd and sometimes
when I go to that direction I like I
don't exactly out of my element so I
know that you know I know when when
someone pays me to go on a court they
want to see the Morea that they see when
I play Wimbledon and that's one oh I
want to deliver and so that's how I
treat everything that I do it's like if
I practice and I'm training or if I have
a meeting and I'm with people that I've
met for the first time like that you
know that first meeting that first
impression takes you to so many
directions um that it's very important
[Music]
Asante rule number two live your truth
you can't really form other people's
opinions of you and you know I became
successful at a very young age and I
like from the first day after winning
Wimbledon you know you would think like
a teenager wins Wimbledon but not
everyone was positive about it everyone
wanted to know the story and you know
blaming my parents for having their
child to go through this crazy journey
and working hard and not having a normal
childhood like everyone is always going
to find something in your success or in
your story or upbringing that will try
to knock you down like literally whether
it's their purpose whether it's a news
outlet whatever it might be you never
know the intention but yeah I don't want
to form people's opinion I just want to
be and live true to who I am everyday
and then that's the only thing that I
can do you can't really control what
other people think of you or how how
they end up remembering you
[Applause]
[Music]
rule number three always keep expanding
I think I've done a really good job in
my career of balancing my career and my
professionalism on the court and doing
what I have to do there and then when
when you get off it expanding into other
things keeping your mind creative
working you know I never had a typical
education so I feel like I learned
through so many things whether it's
business or advertising through maybe
educational things that I would have
learned in school or internships I could
have taken I've actually learned through
working with brands and being in in
meetings and in rooms with people that
are extremely talented in their
departments and knowledgeable at what
they do
and that's part of the reason I wanted
to start something on my own because I
felt like I did have that experience
from learning from them
rule number four visualize I definitely
see this this r1 seems to have this
aspect of rushing like rushing to get to
the next step and rushing to make a
certain amount of money and when I when
I think of goals I don't necessarily
think of specifics I just think of more
feelings of how I would feel when I get
to that what is my success and how does
that feel like instead of saying okay I
want to I want to win this amount of
titles and I want to win this amount of
Grand Slams or I want to earn this
amount of money I think not always I
think more of the feeling how am I going
to feel when I win match point I
visualize it I embrace that feeling and
I carry it with me
like you visualize it all the time or in
the moment I think moments and and I
think it always comes when you least
expect it sometimes you can be on a on a
run sometimes those long plane rides
where you know it's sunset and it's just
you and you've been traveling and you're
going home and you have no one around
you just yourself on the flight it's
just a bunch undreds of strangers next
to you and you have this moment where
you start thinking of why you're doing
this why are you lonely why are you in
this position and you think of what
you've already done to get there and
where you would like to see yourself go
so it those moments always come at a
different I don't I don't sit down and I
think okay right now I'm going to
visualize the feeling that I might have
what I'm just going to tournament or
yeah but I definitely I think it's
important to me when you say things or
you know and I want a friend of mine
says something negative and I was like
don't put that in the universe I put
that out there yeah I do believe in that
there's some sense of them truth in that
because it's also comes with then you
carry with that attitude you know when
someone says something negative you
usually see their attitude change and
shows up in your body and you're yeah
yeah and I mean I for sure do that as
well and I have my moments and but the
faster you acknowledge it and realize it
the faster you can move on
Wow
through the highway
shadow rule number five be laser-focused
when I get to the courts and you know I
have my bag and I'm wearing my my hat in
my in my hoodie this is my office
like that's my workplace and I am like
I'm laser focus and I've had that I mean
I I think it's that mentality that
whatever I just have that tunnel vision
and that's how I go and when I leave the
courts I got friends family jokes fun
like when I get to my office I close the
door and that's me that's you yeah
rule number six my personal favorite
challenge yourself battle that on a
performance that was very special as was
the resistance in the fight that was
shown by Venus Williams but she was
outplayed
that's one of the heaviest defeats meted
out for Venus Williams in Grand Slam
tennis Sharapova is back to her very
very best you've won our the title so we
you've done the Grand Slams in the US
Open and all of that when you look at
now going ahead it's an Olympic gold
that you would want or as a tennis
player what more is there especially an
Olympic gold would be special but did I
hit the nail on the head or not yeah you
did but I I think you said I still go
into every Grand Slam and I still you
know inside of me deep down I have to
feel like I still haven't wanted because
you still have to have that hunger when
you go out on the court because if you
go out on the court and you feel like
I've done this I've done that I do it
every single day that's not fun you have
to challenge yourself and I go out there
and I you have to work just as hard if
not harder I mean the tennis has become
much more physical much more mental than
it's ever been and you have to keep
striving for being better and I've
personally never had a proper education
so no matter how much money I made on
the tennis court I didn't I don't want
that to stop I didn't want to my
thinking to stop when you're on the
court it's like not only is it physical
and it's you're putting in so much
physical work but so much of it is
mental and that's that's the challenge
that I've had since I was a
four-year-old girl is the the mental
side of the game and and I wanted to
find challenges and other in other
different areas in business I thought
would was one of them because I've
always been interested in seeing how
things come alive and how they do and
what works and what doesn't
see
rule number seven develop discipline I
do think that with an it's not just in
sport but with with other things I do
believe that the more you repeat certain
things whether it is writing working on
your you know whether it's cursive
letters or whatever it is like when you
work on something and you keep doing it
over and over it's inevitable that it
will get better and by that you're
creating this feeling of repetition
which leads to discipline like you know
you can do it over and over again and
that's one of my first one of my first
coaches Robert Lansdorp who I speak
about in the book like that was his
philosophy is you I would take a lesson
from him and his philosophy was just
hitting and grinding and it wasn't about
patterns or anything which you know as I
could get from somebody else but what he
gave me is that feeling that I could hit
the ball from any part of the court and
feel like I could do it with closed eyes
and make it and know exactly where it's
going and I'm for me it started at a
young age like my mom would would make
me memorize this Russian literature that
I did not appreciate at five years old
it was very difficult and I didn't know
what it meant but I would do it and I
would memorize it and then I would feel
that I accomplished something I don't
know why I don't know but the repetition
led me to this discipline and and I
think that helps with mindset
we'll go
rule number eight is be unstoppable you
start the book and you go immediately to
the the doping suspension right yeah I
mean I rely I had to I wanted to be open
about it as I'd been from the very
beginning it was from an athletes
perspective it was one of the toughest
things that I had to go through and I
feel like sharing that feeling that I
had and the vulnerability that I had to
carry myself with and for someone that's
so strong and like mentally tough and
have always I mean at six to like you
know passionate about what she does it
felt really small with one of the first
few times in my life where I would just
I didn't want to right I didn't want to
continue writing the book it took a long
time to put those words onto paper and I
felt that that was an important it's
part of my journey it's part of the
reason why my book is called unstoppable
because I've had this mentality from a
very young age that no matter what is
thrown at you they're there it's going
to be roadblocks and you have to
overcome them and you can
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
some Python shadows walking home
welcome with a game on
rule number nine build a great team I
think you have to love what you do you
have to have I mean you you have to have
a plan you have to have good people
around you it's not it's also about a
great tits tits teamwork I mean I have a
very close knit of people that have had
for many years as part of my team and
manager and in a group that every day
wakes up and things how to build and
work and inspire from each other and and
keep it fresh and fun to me don't know
what I mean
and rule number ten before three very
special bonus clips is have fun alright
your distance all right you can go first
on this one thank you yeah I am a nice
girl already
okay okay I'm warming up I'm warming up
okay
keep rolling keep rolling baby come on
no you cannot do better than that don't
think so
let's see it I think the hole is that
way see the flag okay I don't think you
can do better thank you baby yeah take a
picture that this is you'll enjoy this
one all right
you think it's possible are you sure
about this one I'm ready we go again wig
give me a best shot
[Laughter]
[Music]
a material attack
now I've got three very special bonus
clips from Maria on having big goals
having role models and being driven by
your rivals that I think you're going to
enjoy but before that question of the
day back to rule number six 6 which was
challenge yourself what is the biggest
challenge that you are giving yourself
right now in your business or in your
life leave in the comments below I'm
really curious to find out thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon and enjoy
the bonus clips
who is your idol growing up and why my
tennis player I think on the court is
Monica Seles I yeah I loved her attitude
and her passion for the game and and the
strength that she had on the court I
always admired Audrey Hepburn I loved
the images of Audrey Hepburn and Marilyn
Monroe yeah and what they stood for and
their personality do you think that
you're the most successful because in
endorsements in business because the
other athletes have chosen not to do it
or because you're you've got a talent in
that area
I never I'd like to think that I'm
successful because I then you don't want
to go for more I've achieved a lot in my
career but to sit here and say that I'm
the best of this or I'm a great tennis
player I don't like to think like that
because it kind of it puts you in a dead
spot I want to have I have bigger goals
I want to be greater and if even if I
don't reach it I still I want to I want
to get up there we almost started I mean
I personally started this rivalry from a
young age witnessing and worshipping
Serena and Venus practicing at this
tennis academy in Florida as a 13 year
old girl with hundreds of kids next to
me and she was already a Grand Slam
champion with her sister
and I you know the single thought that I
had was I wanted to beat her in a few
years later I find myself it was rude
earlier someone took me and put me into
a television screen of facing Serena
Williams in a final and I'm someone that
honestly did not belong there I mean I
had nothing I was not ready I was not as
tall as I as I gotten to be I was far
from being as strong or physically
capable of competing in two weeks but
somehow I was there and I was facing her
and and she was intimidating she was
strong her presence was there her
confidence the confidence that she's
played with for so many years and you
know so much of is talked about and I
know that a lot of the headlines a lot
of the experts that were chosen from the
book has been about Serena and
rightfully so because so much of it has
been talked for years on end but deep
down there's an incredible amount of
respect that I have for her and and one
of the things I speak about in the book
it's almost like we should be friends
because we understand what it's like
every
and not just by playing tennis not
forehands and backhands but we know
everything that goes with the sport the
pressures the responsibilities the
sponsors the professionalism the press
conference everything that we face it's
almost like we have so many like common
factors and yet we we have to be rivals
in order to beat each other you know we
must have that drive against each other
and having her across the net only makes
you a better player because the her
level is on another planet raise your
standard Apple at the core its core
value is that that people passion and
not one drop of most self-worth depends
on Europe it's supposed to mean
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten most a success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link the description for details